we've got an update on a story about a
man in missouri who's been in prison for
more than 40 years despite evidence that
he's innocent 62-year-old kevin
strickland has been behind bars since
1978
now even county prosecutors want him
released but they are in a fight with
the state's attorney general aaron
moriarty has reported on this
extensively and joins us now erin good
morning
it's a surreal case good morning
in august a new law went into effect in
missouri making it easier for
prosecutors to reinvest investigate
convictions and ask for the release of
inmates that they believe are innocent
when the local prosecutor determined
that strickland was factually innocent
most believe he'd soon be a free man but
five months later he's yet to have his
day in court
to be honest kevin
i thought when i saw you next it would
be on the outside
i was
hoping it would be
also it's been 42 years since kevin
strickland was sent to prison for a
crime he says he didn't commit and this
past may jackson county prosecutor jean
peters baker publicly agreed with him it
is
important to recognize when the system
has made wrongs
and what we did in this case was wrong
yet five months later the 62 year old
remains behind bars i hold fast to my
faith that god ain't gonna let me die in
this jail
but i'm
losing
belief in that the system
is gonna work how old were you when you
were first incarcerated about to be 19
about three months and i'm wondering if
i'm going to be here at 63.
why the delays and the roadblocks that
are being put up
seem to be endless roadblocks thrown up
by the state's attorney general eric
schmidt who maintained strickland
received a fair trial and is guilty it's
the state versus the state instead of
the state versus kevin strickland eric
wesson editor at the kansas city call
devoted the cover of his july 4 issue to
strickland's story the state is arguing
amongst themselves on how to do this who
can present this who has the
jurisdiction to say something in the
case who can't say anything it's really
really sad after a triple homicide in
kansas city in 1978
the only survivor 20-year-old cynthia
douglas identified strickland as one of
the shooters i requested a lineup why
did you request the lineup i hadn't done
anything wrong and i knew once cynthia
saw me
she would recognize well it wasn't kevin
and instead what happened after the
lineup
they told me i was under arrest my mind
and brain and heart and everything went
to my feet this is not happening this is
unbelievable
they're still going to get it right
after his first trial ended with a hung
jury strickland was later convicted and
sentenced to life without parole they
didn't stay out no more than 30 minutes
of deliberation
decided kevin strickland was a murderer
still remember hearing that verdict yeah
yeah i will never forget that
i didn't know i could cry like that at
that age strickland remained in prison
even after two of the four actual
shooters vincent bell and kim atkins
stated under oath that strickland had
nothing to do with the murders the
jackson county prosecutor says that when
douglas realized she had identified the
wrong man she tried to recant her
testimony in 2009 douglas wrote to the
court the midwest innocence project and
told family and friends friends like
eric wesson and why did she come here
because she knew me she trusted me and
she kind of wanted to get it off of her
conscience did she feel a lot of guilt
she felt a lot of guilt about it because
she always said i got this man sitting
in prison for something that he didn't
do a new state law went into effect in
late august that entitled strickland to
a hearing to prove his innocence but his
court date has already been postponed
twice
every one of the shooters all four none
of them are serving time right now for
that murder but you were sitting in here
right
i've been in prison for
43 years
yeah
it's tough it's real tough it hurts you
know i can't get i can't get that 43
back there's nothing that
they could do to make that right my
whole life
is a memory of prison
i don't know anything else
on friday a judge ruled that the next
hearing for strickland's release won't
happen until november 8th to give the
attorney general's office more time to
gather evidence to show why strickland
shouldn't be released the attorney
general's office has declined our
numerous requests for an interview
saying it doesn't comment on pending
cases it's not like strickland was just
going to be released the prosecutor jean
peters baker has to
show to the court and prove
by clear and convincing evidence that
he's innocent so i'm not really sure why
the attorney general is fighting this no
it's maddening when you when you listen
to the facts and you hear the
prosecutors say
five months ago this guy should be
released you've interviewed him twice
erin anything stand out to you about him
well i asked kind of a trite question to
him at one point i said you know do you
hope to get your life back and he looked
at me and he went get my life back i
haven't had a life i'd like to
and
have
a
i see he's in a wheelchair now yeah he
is he can't stand for any period of time
he really wanted to see his mother
before she died
and she died in august he and he wasn't
allowed to go to the funeral well let's
hope they're watching your piece this
morning we'll figure out a way to
resolve this sooner rather than later
that's not right and let's hope the case
comes down to guilt or innocence not
politics right yes which is playing a
part because the attorney general is
running for senate first and that
filters everything and a little bit of
race too oh a race all the way through
he had an all-white jury that convicted
him okay a whole lot of grace
all right aaron thank you very much